yeah ten kills in a row up were you
watching
oopsie that was just me playing with my
new for honor view ten phone just look
at the screen look how big this screen
is it's not as big as my mouse pad but
it's still pretty big
I can play comfortably five and a half
hours of gaming on this thing for real I
really love this phone if you guys want
to preorder it you can do that from now
until the 22nd of March and you will get
a $30 free gift card which you can apply
to buying this phone now they didn't
tell me to tell you this but for the
price range this is in this offer
combined it's an amazing deal and you
get an amazing gaming phone for it it
also has one of my favorite options
which is the game suite so you can add
in your game and optimize it for gaming
mode but also the best thing which is
the uninterrupted gaming mode so if I
happen to get a phone call while I'm
playing you don't want it to interrupt
you here I'm getting a call from Marta's
yeah it shows up and I could just click
it away so easily and there's no problem
and I can just keep going so yeah
definitely make use of that offers check
out the link in the description and now
let's get started with the video
sometimes you just got to look back at
your history and pay your respect
you got a revisit a path and say an AMA
say I will now of course do what made me
popular on YouTube which was play video
games but not just any video game I'm
talking about the horror games well
because there's not enough good ones I
wait for the quality ones to come out
like 3 a.m. at Krusty Krab that's right
that's what we're playing all right high
graphics please I want to really see the
pores full disclosure I am [ __ ]
myself am I playing as it's the crab oh
my god
this is just like the anime holy cow I
have so much money this is what horror
games will get you guys all right what
do we got controls interact I can crouch
in case I need to go down on mr. Finch
babe all right so anything else I need
to know I can read that ok object this
oh wait I need to know objectives gather
all the money all right
argh actively leftover I can't even
Krabby Patties ok pack the leftover
check the bathroom trash for bin that no
way I can't read lock up and leave
alright it seems he view them check the
bathroom trash ok
what happened yeah oh oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no I'm oh I can't this is too
scary no when the light starts blinking
you must hide [ __ ] uh Shh
closing the American aid office ok oh
thank god oh thank god alright where's
the Krabby Patties I gotta pack them and
packing them come on pack them quicker
project him complete I did it damn it
alright let's go everybody come on pack
them pack up we don't have time mr.
Crabb please
back him quicker oh he's coming he's
coming I actually genuinely got scared
no that was just me overreacting like a
fake I don't actually get scared guys
what do you think I am some sort of man
childish screens at video games that
ain't me Oh God
Oh God what is he doing what is he doing
where did he go oh my gosh alright then
I have to do something with the soda
machine I know I need to check the
bathroom so let's do that
here we go oh yeah the bin loot the cash
in the bin okay here we go oh god he's
coming oh god I love the jump scare
sound it's really good Oh God
closer closer he's right there he's
right oh thank god oh thank the Lord
thank the crusty padding oh if we make
it out of live gross that's right I'm
gonna make a fried a sweet PewDiePie
oh my gosh I of course what was a you
got a you got a make really weird faces
for the thumbnail for no reason at all
the 2013 mmm a gay face ken hey hush
hamburger am i right guys alright listen
come on come on guys we can do this
although I'm do oh god we can't pack the
krabby patty pack the krabby patty back
the krabby patty
the tension is killing me this is too
exciting I don't know what to do it's
the oven still on it's shaking okay oh
god I can't fail what the heck man I'm
genuinely not scared at all this game is
too silly did I get the thing in the
bathroom I forgot okay I did we got the
money we got the burger what
is there check the bathroom check the
leftover gather all the money from the
cash register
Oh God oh my god he's after me Oh what
if I die oh I made it I made it
why is the Danish flag here top
disgusting we get all the cash thank you
thank you very much
objective complete thank you okay oh my
god I just got to lock up and leave
that's all I have to do Felix but be
careful there might be okay I feel so
immersed I'm in the game my whole
character and they should make this for
beer okay here we go
how do I leave what the hell I can't
leave gather all the money uh-huh argh
pack the leftover check the bathroom
trash lock up and leave there must be
another egg say that was my genuine
reaction mixed with the exes oh my god
oh my god sorry guys I need I need some
cute time with my dog
yes he's wearing a nappy and he was six
years old that's okay put it's just a
video game
no wait Garrett's not this is serious I
understand like if I'm actually scared
of a game it's fun to follow along but
what's the point like the last good
horror game that I came out was the
Resident Evil 7 and that was fun cuz it
was a good game
but then I get [ __ ] in between for like
not playing and playing enough horror
ashay saw me
but he couldn't all right all right all
right this should be it oh my god we
actually did it
absolutely wait where do I get the lock
key from oh no do I got a finder or
something what do you mean I did all the
objectives help me out of nowhere I
don't feel at least bit dead inside
playing this trust me I feel great all
right we did all the objectives I wish
we'd done now about 500 times why can't
I leave you best not teleport on me what
there must be something out oh I can
jump oh I didn't look the cash register
oh my god this is the most important one
of them all hey want to hear my my
spongebob impression Oh God
hey beat it I'm spongebob and I'm
running the heck out of here oh my god I
am being what the hell I did everything
oh god he sees me oh my dude oh my god
I almost got me no no we're not
oh hey look at that ass son
damn you look good all right where's the
key there must be a key I'm getting
really [ __ ] annoyed this is why I
don't play horror games cuz they're all
God no no no no no no no no no I'm gonna
actually do everything in order cuz I
think the game might be actually that
[ __ ] okay we did it we did it would
that oh he teleported in the bathroom
it's just a random thing like all right
all right pack all the burgers okay okay
KKK this is our chance
there's just no moment mommy come on
baby oh the exit complete oh my god I
did I find the key in the basement lock
up I get out oh my god oh my god gross
oh my god Bros Bros if we do this you
have to subscribe and
I'm a bro today that was it I did it oh
god oh my god no play more there's the
keys somewhere in the basement you must
find it okay bro ChaCha
Oh Mike where's the key job lovely
victim oh my god I just sworn in Swedish
unintentionally that's awesome leave a
like on this video guys J says no do not
make me redo all that I swear to God if
you make me read no thank God okay thank
you I am loosing it guys I never been
this scared out of old horror games
amnesia penumbra that's all the ones I
played do you think it's random where
the key is spawned or do you think it's
the same any everytime I think it's same
every time you found the key now get out
of there oh my god oh hey listen let's
do it
there's the ladder guy Bruce yeah oh my
gosh you had the key now go outside and
lock up what do you mean go go go go go
go Bruce how do I even lock this you
know what whatever I don't care it's
done how is this game still going on
come bucket what do you mean why oh oh
my car my car my car of course oh I
don't know man
so I can't leave then I'm not logged is
that way Oh left mouse button to lock
the door now get to the okay okay we did
it we did it brush oh my gosh
Friday's repeater pie is gonna be epic
this week guys
oh my god are we gonna make it oh my god
[Music]
Jess oh my god we got to put on some
epic music to celebrate all right guys
smash that like button and check out
next week's Friday's repeat bye
it's gonna be late and remember brofist
[Music]